so our most popular dish here at
bigley's is our brisket hey what's up
everybody my name is Rashad Jones I'm
the owner and founder of Big League
series about barbecue here in Ocala
Florida we are a food truck company and
we're cooking up some amazing barbecue
for all of Central Florida to check out
we tend to these cuts of meat while
they're on the smokers as you can see in
the back we only cook on Kiln dried
Central Florida oak wood we're just
doing it in a very old school way so
when you throw a cut of brisket on a
smoker that's been trimmed it's been
seasoned well with a house made dry rub
and it cooks for hours when a customer
bites into that they realize that this
is the barbecue experience they've been
looking for for their entire lives
as a chef I'm always asked where to go
if you're ever in the Jacksonville area
I would recommend silkies from what I've
seen with Chef Kenny Gilbert he just
takes them and puts this incredible spin
on his food elevate it but just a new
approach to Southern Cuisine so the next
time I'm here in Florida I want you to
check us out here at bigley's